- HUH.
WE NEED TO GET YOU A NEW LOOK.
YOU JIVE TURKEY.
WORD UP.
HMM,
HOW ABOUT A RETRO LOOK?
♪ SWING LOW, SWEET CHARIOT
HMM.
I LIKE IT,
BUT I NEED A STYLE
THAT'S ALL MY OWN.
THAT'S IT.
[rap music]
♪
- [gasps]
WOW. WHO ARE YOU?
- BLACK STEVE, BABY.
- DO YOU MIND
IF I TOUCH YOUR HAIR?
- NOT AT ALL.
[boing]
SEE, DENZEL!
THERE'S NO RACISM.
THESE PEOPLE LOVE ME.
- YOU LOOK DUMB AS HELL.
WELL, MIGHT AS WELL EMBRACE
MY NEW CULTURE.
[eerie music]
♪
- [distorted]
BIKRAM YOGA.
- [slowed speech]
BABYBJORN.
- [distorted]
ARCADE FIRE.
- [slowed speech]
GLUTEN-FREE.
- [screams]
- BRO, YOU FORGOT YOUR...
[slowed speech]
CARAMEL MACCHIATO.
- I CAN'T TAKE BEING WHITE!
I GOT TO GET BACK
TO MY ROOTS.
[dramatic music]
- NAH, LOOK OUT!
HE'S GONNA GRAB YOU!
HEY, READING RAINBOW!
DON'T LET THEM PUT YOU
ON THAT SLAVE SHIP!